Yo le abrí la cabeza a un ciego.
No lo hice pensar o reflexionar,
le abrí la cabeza literalmente.
Él venía tomado de mi hombro,
no calculé que ocupaba un espacio
hacia el costado de mi cuerpo,
y lo hice chocar contra
un portón de rejas.
(Risas)
Cinco puntos en la frente.
Me sentí en este momento
el peor profesor del mundo.
La verdad, no sabía cómo pedirle perdón.
Por suerte el Pulga es de esas personas
que se toman las cosas bastante bien.
Y es el día de hoy que sigue diciendo
que yo fui el entrenador que dejó
la marca más importante en su carrera.
(Risas)
La verdad que cuando entré
a trabajar al instituto para ciegos,
me sorprendí de un montón de cosas.
Un montón de cosas que ellos hacían
y yo no imaginaba que podían hacer:
hacían natación, atletismo,
jugaban al truco, tomaban mate,
se lo cebaban ellos y no se quemaban.
Pero cuando vi que jugaban
al fútbol, me pareció increíble.
Tenían una cancha de tierra con
dos arcos oxidados y redes rotas
y los ciegos que iban al instituto
armaban su partidito de fútbol,
igual que el que hacía yo en
el potrero de la esquina de casa,
pero ahí se jugaba sin ver.
La pelota tenía un sonido
para que puedan localizarla;
había un guía detrás del arco rival
para saber a dónde tenían que patear
y se ponían un antifaz.
Había algunos chicos que
tenían un resto de visión
y para que estén todos igual
usaban ese antifaz.
Cuando entré un poquito
en confianza con ellos,
me animé a pedirles un antifaz,
me lo puse y traté de jugar;
había jugado al fútbol toda mi vida.
Me pareció más increíble todavía,
a los dos segundos ya no sabía
dónde estaba parado.
En realidad, yo había
estudiado Educación Física
porque me encantaba el alto rendimiento.
Había entrado a trabajar
ahí de casualidad.
Mi otro trabajo era con
la selección argentina de remo,
y sentía que eso era lo mío.
Acá me costaba todo el doble.
No me voy a olvidar nunca el primer día
que hice la entrada en calor del equipo,
y los puse frente a mí, tenía toda
la experiencia de la selección de remo,
y les dije: "Bueno, ahora
todo el mundo abajo",
hice esto (Agachándose)
cuando levanté la vista había 2 sentados,
3 acostados, otros en cuclillas.
(Risas)
¿Cómo hago para hacer lo mismo
que estaba haciendo allá, acá?
Me costó bastante.
Empecé a buscar herramientas,
a aprender de ellos,
de los profes que ya trabajan con ellos.
Aprendí que no podía explicar una jugada
en un pizarrón como hace un técnico,
pero sí podía usar una bandeja de plástico
con tapitas para que me interpreten
a través del tacto.
Aprendí que ellos también podían
correr en una pista de atletismo
si yo corría con ellos
tomados de una soguita.
Entonces empezamos a buscar voluntarios
que nos ayuden a correr con ellos.
Y me fue gustando y le fui encontrando
el objetivo y el sentido a la actividad.
Me costó, al principio era incómodo,
pero me propuse superar esa incomodidad.
Y llegó un momento en que fue, de todos
mis trabajos, el que más me apasionó.
Creo que fue ahí cuando me pregunté,
¿por qué no podíamos ser nosotros,
también, con los ciegos,
un equipo de alto rendimiento?
Claro, faltaba la otra parte,
había que ver qué querían ellos,
los verdaderos protagonistas
de esta historia.
No iban a alcanzar ya las tres horas
en la canchita esa de tierra
en la que hacíamos fútbol.
Había que entrenar de otra forma.
Empezamos a exigir y la respuesta
fue magnífica: pedían más.
Entendí que ellos también se preguntaban
por qué no podían ser de alto rendimiento.
Cuando nos sentimos preparados,
fuimos a golpear las puertas del CENARD,
el Centro Nacional de Alto Rendimiento
que tenemos aquí en este país.
Nos costó bastante que nos abran,
pero nos costó bastante más
que los otros deportistas que ya
entrenaban ahí nos consideren pares.
En realidad nos prestaban la cancha
solo cuando ningún otro equipo la usaba.
Y éramos "los cieguitos", no sabían
todos qué hacíamos ahí adentro.
El mundial del 2006 fue una bisagra
en la historia del equipo.
Era la primera vez que
se hacía en Buenos Aires
y era nuestra oportunidad
de mostrarle a los nuestros
lo que veníamos haciendo hace un tiempo.
Llegamos a la final, veníamos
creciendo como equipo.
En la final del otro lado estaba Brasil;
había sido el mejor equipo del torneo.
Ganaba todos los partidos por goleada.
Casi nadie confiaba en que nosotros
podríamos ganar ese partido.
Casi nadie menos nosotros.
En la concentración y en el vestuario,
en cada entrenamiento
había olor a campeón.
Les juro que ese olor existe.
Yo lo sentí varias veces con el equipo,
pero recuerdo particularmente
el día anterior a jugar esa final.
La Asociación de Fútbol Argentino
nos había abierto las puertas
y estábamos concentrados en AFA, donde
concentraban Verón, Higuaín, Messi.
Para nosotros era sentirnos una selección
de verdad por primera vez.
En la charla técnica, el día
anterior, siete y media de la tarde,
estábamos en el salón
y un mozo golpea la puerta,
interrumpiendo la charla,
para proponernos ir a una iglesia,
nos vino a invitar a ir a un iglesia.
Yo trato de disuadirlo, diciéndole
que no era el mejor momento,
que lo dejemos para otro día.
Y él insiste diciéndome que, por favor,
los deje llevar a los chicos a la iglesia
porque ese día iba un pastor
que hacía milagros.
Le pregunté con un poquito de
miedo a qué milagro se refería,
y muy suelto me dijo: "Profe, déjeme
llevar al equipo a la iglesia
que cuando volvemos estoy
seguro de que la mitad ve".
(Risas)
Se escuchó alguna carcajada pero imaginen
uno ciego y que le estén diciendo eso.
Yo no supe qué responderle, me quedé
callado, se hizo un silencio incómodo.
Yo no quería hacerlo sentir mal, porque
él realmente creía que eso podía pasar.
Y me sacó de ese apuro un jugador,
que se levantó y muy seguro le dijo:
"Juan, Gonza ya te dijo que no es
el mejor momento para ir a la iglesia.
Pero déjame aclararte otra cosa:
llegamos a ir a esa iglesia
y yo cuando volvemos yo estoy
entre la mitad de los que ve,
te recago a trompadas, porque mañana
no puedo jugar el partido".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Juan se fue riéndose y algo resignado,
seguimos con la charla técnica,
y esa noche, cuando me fui a dormir,
empecé a soñar en mi cabeza
el partido del día siguiente,
imaginar qué podía pasar,
cómo íbamos a jugar.
Y ahí es donde sentí ese olor a campeón
que les dije hace un ratito.
Porque en ese momento yo sentí
que si el resto de los jugadores
tenían las mismas ganas que
Diego de jugar ese partido,
no podíamos no ser campeones.
El día siguiente iba a ser maravilloso.
Nos levantamos a las 9 de la mañana,
el partido era a las 7 de la tarde
y nosotros ya queríamos ir a jugar.
Salimos de AFA y en el micro
que estaba lleno de banderas
que la gente nos había regalado,
veníamos charlando sobre el partido
y escuchábamos bocinazos
y gritos de gente que nos decía:
"Vamos Murciélagos, hoy es
el último día, el último esfuerzo".
Los chicos me preguntaban:
"¿Nos conocen? ¿Saben que jugamos?"
Había gente que iba al CENARD
siguiendo el micro.
Llegamos y nos encontramos
con un marco increíble.
Y en el trayecto del vestuario
hacía la cancha
yo venía caminando con Silvio
tomado de mi hombro, guiándolo,
-- por suerte no había ningún portón
de rejas en el camino --
y cuando llegamos a la cancha,
él me preguntaba de todo,
no se quería perder ni un detalle.
Entonces me decía: "Contame qué ves,
contame quién está tocando esos bombos".
Yo trataba de explicarle qué pasaba,
lo más detalladamente posible.
Le decía: "Están las tribunas llenas,
se quedó un montón de gente afuera,
hay globos celestes y blancos
por toda la cancha,
están abriendo una bandera gigante de
Argentina que ocupa toda la tribuna..."
En un momento me interrumpe y me dice:
"Fijate si ves una bandera
que diga San Pedro",
la ciudad donde él vive.
Empiezo a buscar en la tribuna
y por allá arriba veo, chiquitita,
blanca y pintada con un aerosol negro,
una bandera que decía: "Silvio,
tu familia y todo San Pedro presentes".
Se lo digo y me dice: "Ahí está mi vieja.
Decime por favor dónde está
que la quiero saludar".
Lo acomodo y con su brazo
le indico dónde está la bandera
y con sus dos brazos
él saluda hacia ese lugar.
Se levantan unas 20, 30
personas a ovacionarlo
y cuando pasa esto veo cómo se le
transforma la cara, cómo se emociona.
Me emocioné yo también,
pero a los dos segundos se me hizo
un nudo en la garganta.
Fue raro, porque sentía la emoción
de lo que estaba pasando,
y la bronca y la angustia de que
no pueda él ver todo esto.
Unos días después cuando lo charlé con él
y le conté lo que me había pasado,
él me tranquilizó porque me dijo:
"Gonza, quedate tranquilo,
yo los vi, de otra forma, pero
te juro que los vi a todos".
Empezó el partido,
no nos podíamos quebrar, era la final.
La gente tenía que estar
así como ahora, en silencio,
porque en el fútbol de ciegos
el público tiene que hacer este silencio
para que escuchen la pelota.
Y había que alentar solamente
cuando el partido estaba detenido.
Eso sí, faltando 8 minutos para el final,
gritaron lo que no habían gritado en 32.
Desde el alma, cuando el chueco
Silvio la clavó en el ángulo,
gritaron ese gol de una forma increíble.
Si hoy van al CENARD,
si pasan por la puerta
van a ver un cartel enorme
con la foto de los Murciélagos.
Son una selección modelo del país,
todos saben quiénes son en el CENARD,
y después de haber ganado dos campeonatos
del mundo y dos medallas paralímpicas,
nadie duda que son de alto rendimiento.
(Aplausos)
Tuve la suerte de entrenar a este equipo,
primero como preparador físico
y después como director técnico
durante diez años.
La sensación que me llevé o que tengo es
que recibí muchísimo más de lo que les di.
El año pasado me propusieron entrenar
otra selección, la de Powerchair Fútbol.
Es una selección argentina de chicos
que juegan al fútbol en sillas de ruedas.
Son sillas de ruedas motorizadas,
que manejan con un joystick,
porque no tienen fuerza en los brazos
para impulsar una silla convencional.
Les ponen como un paragolpes,
como una defensa a la silla
que además de proteger sus pies
les permite patear la pelota.
Es la primera vez que ellos dejan de ser
espectadores, para ser protagonistas.
Es la primera vez que sus papás,
sus amigos, sus hermanos,
los pueden ir a ver jugar a ellos.
Para mí es un nuevo desafío.
De vuelta la incomodidad, la inseguridad,
el miedo de cuando empecé con los ciegos.
Sí, lo enfrento con más experiencia.
Por eso desde el primer día los trato
como deportistas dentro de la cancha,
y tratando de ponerme en
el lugar de ellos afuera.
Sin ningún prejuicio, porque tratándolos
naturalmente es como mejor se sienten.
Los dos equipos juegan al fútbol,
era algo impensado para ellos.
Tuvieron que adaptar las reglas
para poder hacerlo, ¿sí?
Y rompieron los dos equipos
con una misma regla,
precisamente, la que decía que
ellos no podían jugar al fútbol.
Cuando uno los ve jugar,
no ve discapacidad, ve competencia.
El problema es cuando termina
ese partido y dejan la cancha,
y salen a jugar nuestro partido.
En una sociedad que establece reglas
que los tienen muy poco
en cuenta, que no los cuida.
Yo aprendí del deporte
que la discapacidad depende
en gran medida de las reglas de juego.
Por eso creo que si cambiamos algunas
de las reglas de nuestro partido,
les podemos hacer la vida
un poco más fácil a ellos.
Todos sabemos que existen personas
con discapacidad, las vemos a diario.
Pero tal vez, al no tener
un contacto directo con ellas,
no somos conscientes de la
problemática que enfrentan día a día.
Lo que les cuesta subir a un colectivo,
conseguir un trabajo, bajar
a un subte, cruzar una calle.
Es cierto que hay una mayor
responsabilidad social
respecto de la inclusión de
las personas con discapacidad.
Pero creo que no es suficiente todavía.
Creo que el cambio debe ser
de cada uno de nosotros.
Primero, dejando de lado
la indiferencia hacia ellos
y después respetando las reglas
que sí los tienen en cuenta.
Son poquitas, pero hay.
Yo le abrí la cabeza a un ciego, al Pulga.
Les puedo asegurar que estos dos
equipos también me la abrieron a mí,
porque me enseñaron sobre todo cómo
hay que salir a jugar cada partido
en este hermoso campeonato que es la vida.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)